Ich bin momentan auf dieser Station gedient, aber der Arzt, ich bin wieder mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschwöhnung.
Wie heißen Sie denn? Mein Name ist Tom Müller.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachname und Vorname stabilen?
Mein Name ist Tom, der Automater.
Nachname ist Müller.
Herr Müller, ich möchte Ihre Beschwerde erzählen.
Ich bin 1,70 m groß.
Ich bin 85 kg.
Ich bin 40 Jahre alt.
Am 2.2.1982.
Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was haben Sie mit der Beschwerde?
Ich habe seit einer Woche Rückenschmerzen.
Das zieht in meine rechte Beine hinein.
Haben Sie eine Unfalle gehabt oder haben Sie ein bayerisches Beweg?
Ich bin morgens aufgestanden und wollte auf die Aubertage gehen.
Ich habe mich gebückt und das war ein einschießender Schmerz.
Seitdem tut mir mein Rücken weh und der Schmerz strahlt in meinen Beinen aus.
Ich habe mich auf eine Schmerz gestartet.
Wie viele Schmerzen haben Sie?
7.
Ich habe die ganze Zeit.
Was ist das Schmerz?
Verstärken.
Sie sind gut aufliegen.
Sie haben schon aufgefallen, dass Sie ein gewöhnliches Gefühl haben?
Nein, ein bisschen gefühlt habe ich nicht aufgefallen.
Sie haben eine Kraftverlust aufgefallen?
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerz.
Ich habe keine Lebung oder Kraftverlust.
Ich habe nicht aufgefallen.
Wie viele Schmerzen haben Sie?
Ich habe die Schmerzen und die helfen mir.
Ich nehme das bei Bedarf ein und das ist ein 800 Milligramm.
Ich nehme die schon dreimal am Tag ein.
Ich nehme die Schmerzen, die ich mit heißem Wasser oder heißem Kisten anbinde.
Ich habe es noch gemacht, ich weiß nicht, ob es gut wird oder nicht.
Herr Müller, sind Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein, ich habe nicht operiert.
Doch, wegen Blindern wurde ich mal operiert, wo ich klein war.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Leiden Sie unter Kopfschmerzen?
Kopfschmerzen habe ich auch nicht.
Ich weiss aus Brücken?
Auch nicht.
Leiden Sie Atemnot oder Kostüm?
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Wasalasen oder Schukran?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Herr Müller, bei Ihnen ist es eine Konkurrenz, eine Schukran-Krankheit oder eine Erinnerung?
Nein, es ist nicht bekannt bei mir.
Sie ist sehr viel geimpft?
Geimpft, ja, ich habe alle Impfungen gemacht auf die Corona-Jaffung.
Vor einem Monat hatte ich die Brust-Impfung gemacht.
Durchführen lassen.
Brauchen Sie?
Ja, eine Packung am Tag.
Das ist zwar langsam teuer jetzt, aber ich kann noch nicht aufwärmen.
Wie lange haben Sie das gemacht?
Seit 15 Jahren.
15 Jahre.
Das war nicht gut.
Sie haben auch Türkisch Alkohol?
Ja, nicht wirklich.
Ein Glas Wein, abends zum Essen trinke ich mir schon.
Wie lange haben Sie das gemacht?
Meistens.
Herr Müller, doch eine Frage für Ihre Familie.
Hat jemand in Ihrer Familie auch eine Erkrankung oder eine Erfahre-Krankheit?
Was meinst du für eine Familie?
Ich habe eine Erkrankung für meine Mutter.
Meine Mutter ist übergewichtig.
Sie nimmt auch Medikamente wegen Schildrüse.
Wie alt ist Ihre Eltern?
Meine Eltern.
Mein Vater ist 75 Jahre alt und meine Mutter ist 69 Jahre alt.
Danke.
Es gibt noch eine Schweste oder eine Pfarrer?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, er ist gesund.
Wie ist Ihr Beruf, Herr Müller?
Wer? Ich?
Ich bin Programmierer, IT-Bericher.
Ich arbeite in der IT-Bericher.
Wie ist Ihr Leben?
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Jawohl.
Herr Müller, ich möchte auf Ihre Beschwerden zurückkommen.
Können Sie mit dem Bein oder normalen Laufen?
Können Sie sich schmerzen oder ein ungewöhnliches Gefeuern?
Es ist ein Dauerschmerz.
Wenn ich laufe, ist es nicht schlimmer oder nicht.
Bravieren Sie eine Unfähigkeit für die Arbeit?
Ich kann nicht lange sitzen.
Ich weiß noch nicht, was ich habe.
Was denken Sie?
Können Sie ein bisschen aushalten?
Ich mache eine Waffe.
Ich gebe eine Jessica Tablet.
Gerne.
Gibt es noch irgendwelche Musiker?
Sonst zu beschwerden? Nein.
Außer meinen Rückenschmerzen bin ich glücklich.
Ja, mit dem Anamnese fertig.
Möchten Sie etwas hinschauen?
Nein.
Was passiert mit mir?
Ich werde Ihnen eine körperliche Untersuchung geben.
Ich werde eine Brut abnehmen.
Ich werde eine Gerundeparameter kontrollieren.
Ich werde die Berge und die Werte bestimmen.
Ich werde auf den Rücken und eine Untersuchung geben.
Sind Sie gefährlich?
Nein.
Diese Untersuchung ist eine moderne Untersuchung.
Diese Untersuchung können wir eine schwache Gewebe und ihre Knochen ganz genau gut erstellen.
Diese Erfahren durch Magnetfeld, eine mitgewöhnene Verfahren für uns erstellen.
Aufgrundlich können wir etwas in den Feld.
Ganz gut und schmerzhaft.
Ich werde eine Berührung oder eine Schmerzmittel geben.
Das ist alles hübsch.
Haben Sie bestimmte Medikamente oder Alergie?
Nein, ich kenne nicht so viele Medikamente.
Auf Kontrast mitnehmen?
Nein, das kenne ich nicht.
Wenn Sie nicht aufstehen oder von Sistön nicht, können Sie nicht aufstehen.
Wir müssen Ihnen im Krankenhaus aufnehmen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Hauptsache, Sie helfen mir, Herr Doktor.
Ich werde Ihnen mit einer persönlichen Person begleiten.
Gehen Sie sofort auf die Station.
Sie sind fertig für die Anamneser.
Sie haben auch irgendwelche urgenten Sachen in der Gruppe.
Sie haben etwas gesichert.
Wenn Sie eine Oberarztvorstellung machen, können Sie dann reden.
Eigentlich ist alles relativ okay.
Sie haben eine spezielle Anamneser gefragt.
Sie haben leicht durcheinander gefragt.
Ich würde eine Struktur reinbauen.
Als Gedankensstütze, sage ich es sehr oft, ich wiederhole noch einmal,
Sie haben schon gefragt, wo Sie eine Parise haben.
Man kann auch fragen, ob Sie sich bei der Temperatur unterschieden haben.
Man hat vielleicht gefehlt, aber ich weiß nicht, ob Sie in der Prüfung so detailiert fragen.
Da gibt es den Begriff, Perfere durch Flutung, Motorizensilität.
Ich wiederhole, dass Sie das einbrennen.
Sie haben das Gefühl, Sie sind gut.
Aber wenn andere Fragen kommen, dann wird Ihre Grammatik und die Sprache ein bisschen falsch.
Sie haben ein bisschen verletzt.
Sie haben das Gefühl, Sie haben das Gefühl, Sie sind gut.
Sie haben eine Programmierung gesagt.
Sie haben seit einer Woche mit einer Woche aufgetretenen Stärke geschmarsen.
Sie haben das Gefühl, Sie haben das Gefühl, Sie sind gut.
Sie haben das Gefühl, Sie sind gut.
Bei den Patienten ist eine Katmosik, ein so genanter Bein,
und die Missentfüllung, die Druckgefühle, verneint.
Sie haben nur eine schmerzhafte Beweglichkeit.
Sie haben eine Schmerzgefühle, die aus weiteren Küken hinzufühlt,
und eine Arbeit nicht fahren könnte.
Sie haben eine Schmerzinfektion, die aus Vorerkrankungen...
Auf eines Schmerzkala, Schmerzintestate, liegt bei 7 von 10.
An Vorerkrankungen und Voroperationen wurde verneint.
Es ist eine Rauche.
Hat der Schmerzmittel eingenommen?
Er ist abgeklungen oder gelindert?
Was denken Sie denn?
Verlässt der Fossilink, bitte.
Vielleicht kann man eine Perferscheuerskrankheit denken.
Damit Sie Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose erhärten oder ausschließen, was es sein kann, haben Sie?
Wir können beide Untersuchungen durch verschiedene Untersuchungen erhören.
Was können Sie machen?
Was haben Sie gesagt?
Ein neurologisches Konzil haben Sie auch ausgestellt.
Ein Neurologist macht eine Neurologie.
Ich habe ein Neurologist-Konsil eingeleitet.
Ein Neurologist-Konsil wurde ausgestellt.